okay let's repeat
uh this hang in there eric we believe in
you
i'm trying i'm trying thanks for
believing in me
i'll repeat the same opening as the
previous
or do i let's mix it up let's play a
semi slot
i don't know what var plays against this
okay semi slot with a6
i know very vague theory thanks for the
bits alexander's horse
and mercury orbit appreciate that
i know there's some reason why i delay
taking
maybe to play this
i think i still want to take with queen
eventually
and then get some kind of so this setup
is kind of
it resembles a kali zuka tort
black will find some nice piece harmony
maybe i can win connect four or maybe
not
have to watch out for bishop a3
it's not too scary though
though i think i'll take first i'll just
not give him the option and then put the
bishop here
i guess i'm giving him the option of
bishop g5 but the knight wouldn't be
pinned
the queen the queen here keep the
pressure
[Music]
yeah so the idea is to play knight
knight c5
question is what is my idea probably 94
to
bring the other knight to f6
i just realized i could try calling him
i could voice call him
maybe after the game i'll try that
and see if he picks up i forgot this
feature existed on leeches
but maybe we can use that to like
briefly analyze
oh also thanks for oh thanks john
welcome back john
thanks for gifting a sub
wait okay let's be focused here
that's kind of an awkward position
bishop b7 i really don't know what my
plan is
i'm gonna play queen v8
i think the queen is just a lot more
useful here i'm also preventing 95.
there's some distant idea of playing
this to pressure this and this too
he prevents me let's prevent him i don't
i don't know if h6 did anything but i'm
just trying to play quick moves at this
point
my whole setup is actually it's directed
towards
i'm playing pawn e5 which is kind of
logical
let's do it this is the opposite of
social distancing
and don't try this at home or in public
okay my pawn is social distancing from
my other pawns at least the definition
of an isolated pawn
so he has a bishop here i have some
attacking potential
knight takes e4
let's go for this
so i'm actually fixing fixing my
structure
i have an id5
pressuring the bishop if the bishop ever
moves i'll have e3 ideas
even bishop f5 first
that move kinda makes me scared
i take i end up trading down a lot
i think i'll play this first repair rook
c8
trying to fight for the one of the only
open files
the drawback of this move is it cuts off
the defense of my queen
i don't really want to trade queens
i do have this idea
it takes
let's go for it i just don't see i'm
curious what he's going to do
maybe this move but now i take and play
knight d3
yeah here rook maybe the other rook
actually this rook should be fine
if here i can play
oh it's tricky
i might just have to move back i've
worked you know rook tea2 doesn't work
let's put move back
like if you make one small mistake he
just punishes you for it
i mean the goal is to play knight three
get some obstacle bishop position
maybe maybe hold on for a draw
okay yeah so even even if my pawn lands
on d3 it looks weak but the bishop will
always defend it
i'll just chill
okay going after the bishop now
now my bishop can plant itself on b5
f5 coming i'm building some nice
kind of construction my rook should
shift back
to one one of the better files
i might even be playing this for a win
now
there's no rook c1 because my knight
control c1
there's that move
and now i'm ready to bring the king in
this bishop is so sad
he doesn't really want to take either
let's defend
good move to go for that
keep walking the king in put the rook
here and then
put the king on d5
interesting what do i do here
i had to try something going for this
move of course he sees it
oh the bishop defends backwards my king
can come in
[Music]
trying to chase the king around somehow
oh i'm not winning anything
it's close
um
how do you gain so much time
i'm turning this now
going for this
attack the rook like that
i think it's close to winning i don't
know though here's this check
okay now it better be winning let's go
kind of
he's gonna try tricky things
okay here i'm planning to take the pawn
with check so if he pushes i take and
defend
oh that took work
i'm not losing all the games i don't
think
yeah no stalemate tricks
good game
okay i feel i feel like i accomplished
my goal
but he he still was playing me
but i guess he also got low on time once
i got my bishop
like i think he over pushed and just
allowed yeah allowed a nice squirt for
my bishop
oh thanks chat for being so supportive
and so happy
gg all right let's move on to the next
one eric i think this is the one you won
this one right the fifth game i'm uh
yeah
we played six in total oh yeah this um
this one was yeah grinding and game
yeah this is the top position yeah i i
was happy with the
i was enjoying the position but then at
some point i started to
um okay i mentioned this during my
stream that
uh this was played in a 2012 world
championship match between
gailfund and anand in that famous game
that gilfond won actually
right to get the lead in the match guys
if you
if you want to look at that that's a
very good game by gale fund
so i i did not mention that in my stream
but i actually i started playing
this opening around then inspired by the
match
but i only i only played this for a few
months and i ended up switching
but it's one of these openings that i
can play every once in a while
yeah yeah
i just didn't really know so much theory
here but i wasn't too
uh too disappointed with the position it
was a playable position i think at some
point you had an a5 move which i thought
might have been very
it might have been critical because um
the key in this position is when they
take you have to take back with the pawn
the main goal and is to get a knight on
uh
c5 and the one idea that is very
important to know when i'm playing b3
pretty much the next move is bishop a3
here and here white wants to get rid of
the dark school bishops if i get the box
of bishops off i can have
a nice outpost on c5 so that's why i
took on
on d4 is just to prevent bishop a3 this
is actually a critical move
uh-huh because let's say you you make a
normal
move you go here and then suddenly
knight a4
and it's it's some big problems now yeah
this this looks kind of annoying and
then
and then roxy one rook c1 and queen c2
and i think it's just
the pawn is gone you can't even take e7
is hanging
so the timing of taking on d4 is very
important because b3 looks like just a
normal move you know playing trying to
play bishop b2 you know nothing
nothing special but actually is it's a
move that creates a threat
with bishop a3 so your timing was
correct to take
i thought uh there was one moment here
that i think this was all fine i was
kind of worried when you played this i
thought this was kind of
important to try to uh
try to uh get rid of the ace because a6
is a weakness
uh i didn't manage to play it properly
in the game but i think it was
it was a problem in the game so i think
i would like to get rid of this
and uh because i can't play b5
because now i'm just losing a pawn
and also if i let's say i want to try to
play
sorry queen is back here
so after a5 let's say i want to go here
then then i have a problem you take
twice on a1 now
um so it's a move that
you know so maybe oh you can't you can't
play rook b1 either because i i fork you
on
c3 yeah so it's actually a move that you
know you get rid of your weakness and
you start
you know some small offensive ideas you
know
so i think uh i'm not sure what to do i
need to find some move here but i'm not
sure what would be the right move here
for me uh yeah it's tricky like i've
i think if a5 was under my radar but i
was um
again in most cases i just assumed b5 i
guess i forgot
i had enough attackers on c5 yeah queen
b8 okay i realized there was some knight
g4 ideas coming up so i that's the
reason i played here
and now i felt very comfortable with the
position because
i kind of got what i you know sure the
the dream set up for this position and
this one came as a surprise but
you know at first i thought this was
maybe not as good but now
and you know during the game as soon as
you played it i realized maybe this was
the right decision because
i didn't know what else to do yeah i'm
just going to go here and
very slowly i'm going to start my
expansion which is going to be very
so i think your play was very
very important here it's still better
for white
but
okay and ideally i don't want to take on
e4
but this d4 is coming up and i don't
have a i don't see a way i can get a
grip on this
yeah no i thought i thought it was a
situation where like the isolated pawn
is actually kind of strong
yeah especially with active pieces maybe
i could have played a little bit more
sophisticated like knight b3 and just
you know
but you know it's always worth you know
you always worry in a blitz game leaving
a lot of pieces like this it's always
some tactics could happen
you know some bishop h3 i don't think it
works right now but i think
there is some potential for you here you
know some
yeah i mean i would be inclined to
attack on the king's side i'm just not
sure what how i execute an attack yeah
um so okay my plan was to take a kick
and i was explaining during the stream
that if i can get this queens off the
uh might should be much better i will
have a big advantage here but i think
you you you you played it very precisely
here this is a critical moment if
i could get the queens without the
knight getting too active then i have
very good winning chances but i think
you played very precisely here
um oh first of all
you could take you know this i consider
that
i just wasn't sure about the resulting
endgame after it takes takes ticks
he wasn't comfortable with the pawn
being kind of stuck and yeah
you have the passport potential i i
think i think
uh you probably made the right decision
this is probably a very unpleasant end
game yeah
also my epon stuck on the light square
as well yeah yeah
now i trade but
so here i went with the trade just for
the concrete line of
knight f4 and eventually knight d3 yeah
okay so probably knight d3 here was
maybe a little bit better because
that's true yeah i um
a6 is hanging so originally i was
thinking something like uh
like rook d2 which probably doesn't work
for a few reasons i mean you have bishop
e3
you also can probably get away with
bishop takes a6
yeah thank you for the sub at the casual
i gotta
uh thank you thank you casual yeah thank
you the chat has been very active
oh that's great to see i have a chance
yeah we had a lot of people watching our
match on my on my
on my uh uh stream that's awesome yeah i
was trying to give some shout outs and
i'm using like this new extension where
people
if people are watching on my stream
they'll see your uh
your avatar and then they can
automatically follow you from my stream
yeah yeah i got i think i got a lot of
thank you so much i think
i got a lot of a lot of followers and uh
yeah
that was great yeah so bishop b60 i
think
now that it's kind of tricky tricky you
go here i have this
you know yeah and then 92 but it doesn't
work like it's um yeah
so it went here and here i can't really
i didn't like my a4 but i didn't know
what to do and it was
it was not enough time not enough time
to
i had a great position and you had 10
seconds and
i i and you you know i i did not manage
to play this correctly
it's not so simple here i was i was i
was trying to
prevent knight d3 but i didn't manage to
you know
uh because i wanted to go here but then
i realized yes
maybe maybe look d1 you know because
because this this i don't mind this side
of mind i can i can you know i can play
this forever and
yeah you can torture me here probably
very very good chances you know
but i think i should play rook d1 and
stop that idea
yeah once i got knight d3 and i was i
was feeling a lot more comfortable
especially once i got bishop e5 a few
moves later
yeah i thought not but now now i think i
lost my age actually because
i don't really want to play a5 because
then you have strong blockade
right and i this still this looks looked
awkward i didn't want to do this
oh here i think i don't have anything i
just thought
uh i can still play for a win but i
think f5 and
i i should be careful now i think
yeah definitely you can start with g5
and even
i i'm i'm just worse here
uh yeah i think i think you're the only
one playing in
yeah like everything was under control
and uh yeah
eventually you have everything out of
control could i have played this
before no d5 it's just a tricky idea
but i think just rotate yeah you're just
controlling everything
and f4 king h2
92 was a threat i couldn't see anything
so it's like okay let me at least try to
trade
this bishop i was hoping to get a b5
break going but i think you were very
accurate okay maybe i should play b5
here
um oh b5 i can maybe start with king c4
yeah and then taking rook 8
i have four you could take one before
too right here
or yeah i mean uh i think i was trying
to win some of the kingside pawns
um or like chase your king around but i
realized it didn't really lead too much
probably a draw somewhere here but
then i i i
yeah i probably should just repeat
probably try repeat right
yeah i played here then after this
and this is tricky this is yeah it comes
down to i think one tempo
right because i can't can i take not
i don't think i can take right if you
take i'm gonna queen
wait i should have done this way and
check
check here i take
oh you're you're fast actually
yeah then i go here i guess yeah i can't
take because you're actually queen first
so it would probably yeah if i take
actually you win
and you start yeah you have to play b6
wow and this is probably just a draw
yeah this is a draw all right okay i
mean this was my original calculation
like
i tried to i just assumed it was winning
for me but i guess it's strong you have
to play this check very quickly win the
a pawn otherwise there could be some
problems
if you don't win so you have to
eliminate this last spawn
otherwise otherwise there could be some
some issues so it's a it's a
it's a draw air yeah yeah i actually
only for some reason i thought you're
just gonna win and
of course leaving the pawn it was just a
you know yeah then just e3
right it was crazy at least at least i
should have checked you
oh wait what if i check i was gonna play
king
oh yeah actually i was expecting check
um
because then you have some rookie two
moves i i think it's the only move
actually
because i think if you go here or
somewhere here i think
that's just you you trade until we then
keep on ending yeah and then our winning
gary because it's p5
yeah yeah so so this is important
so you have to go here
and now i need to okay it's just a draw
probably yeah
rock rook b2 maybe rook a2 yeah
okay i want to go b or rook b2 i want to
play b5 and a5 so you probably just i
guess i could
check and go for something like e3 oh
unless you have king e3 though
so i go here okay then you check again
and then you can take the pawn and check
again i go here
if i go away it takes i have to go here
and you check again
but you know it's it's like it's
probably a draw but
maybe i mean you might actually have
winning chances if you can win the pawn
so yeah i should have done that yeah how
much time i had yeah this
rookie six was just terrible and i
played it quickly too i still had
16 seconds yeah i mean i think it's
objective it's probably a draw here uh
we just we just need to find the okay i
think i see it
maybe something like this this this it
it's funny that you know even though
you're up a part but it's you have to be
a little bit more careful here
right uh i think you have to go check
here
because the king is badly placed i think
you go check
here you go check and you play something
like
this um oh just hold my grounds yeah
yeah and then you have your h pawn and
this
should be just draw so i think this is
very important
yeah it's not always easy to figure out
in these uh these time scramble
situations
yeah no absolutely yeah absolutely